I had a girlfriend, but I
was confessed to by another girl
[music]
What should
I do?  I'm the happiest person in the world
.
Ah,
eh, did
you think I would do
that?
I
'm sure I'll take it again with this, or put it on
benan Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh  That's right, but
I don't want to lie about my feelings, and I always tell people I love them, but
it's an academic conference, so
I confess once a month through the shoji screens, and I open here and get water.
I'm Ohno for elementary and junior high school students
.
I'm happy to have a girlfriend
elona
open me
ana
ran
ni
[music]
ah ah
ah ah ah ah
me
[music]
ah ah ah
me
[music]
tan
pane
haa
[music]
sorry i didn't even introduce myself
hyooeh nice to meet you i'm 1st year Minase Nagisa please
Well, how about my 3 no?
I said I'd do my best for
3 months
Red jogging Let's do it for 4 hours now I'm using the time before bed to improve myself I'm a very hard worker I'm a very hard worker I approached
Fukuhiro with a system of 1000 fans What a muscular man's heart  It
seems like it's something you
grab with your stomach, so I've just finished practicing on the street
.
On top of that
, the taste is doubled and I bought Matsusaka beef i Maintenance is based on the power of materials such as bras
[music]
masana
oh
th
was it me
?
I won't give up just because I've been given
[music]
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah yeah
I
want to live my life by your side, I don't want to sell you I
can't betray her, so if you'll let me
[music]
[applause]
ah ah ah
2 Can I give it to her together?  Shall we go and listen?
ana
In addition, there are four episodes, but I
wonder if
it's okay.
ha ha yes
9 b 8 let's go out now
, okay?
Sports n Faye
pants too  If you're cute, I'm in
the Fukuchi where I came to my bride. It's a yukata.
Saki
-chan I want to go straight through this wood. I understand
that feeling
.
Actually, I was confessed to by everyone
just now The more I do it, the more attractive this is To be honest, I'm attracted to
this
already 4
I have no choice but to do it
again  I have no choice but to do it
[Applause]
Hahahaha
par
I don't know how powerful it is, but that's
why as a person I can't secretly
do things
like fork in two.
It's not possible
[music]
I want you to
talk about it.
I
don't think I can break up with Mr. Sasaki with my powers,
and if I don't get
backed
up
, I'll be dumped.
It's common sense, isn't it?
But it's true that I was attracted to Mr.
Minase, but I'm lying to myself and Saki-chan to keep going out with her because it's super
formal.
I think there are regrets in both lying and bifurcation, so
I don't want to be honest with myself and challenge myself.
Yeah yeah yeah I wo
n't make any effort to make you resist my two-pronged relationship
Just try it,
that's okay [music] I'll be someone I won't have a hot pot any time
I will cherish Taku-chan and raise 30,000 yen every month
Then
I won't do anything I can
do.Nuntan I think it's selfish to do anything else.I think it's only
natural for Saki-chan to dump me on this occasion
.  also
the  Stick to the reporter
[music]
I'm glad I got caught
.  I think, but thank you I
'll do my best I've come to dislike Naoya a little because of the number of orders I'll do my best Oh, it's too early So
what are you going to do from now on?
It seems that there is absolutely no good place From
today, the three of
us will live at home
Ah, I'm not resting at home
The three of us live, it
's like a dream Then I'll prepare a room for two
] It's the one from
no 8, isn't it Smells good in here
[music]
par
is ready to take a bath
symbol mechanism
kimchi
zakicha  Hey, can I come in with
you? j
wh
Yay, I want to talk
with you, no?
[Music]
Sakina Yes, don't worry about me tonight
.
Please
[music]
am
I
don't have a single piece to say good
or bad, huh?
I'm sorry to be sullen -
what do you
say? We haven't said anything yet, so sorry for the stars  Well,
kisses like that are still
[music], are
n't they
[music]
?
But in the
first place, we've only been dating for a short time,
and we're still childhood friends, so
it's not a good
idea to spend a lot of time in vain.
Hey, I'm bending the video,
how far is
fine?  Haa
, if you're a princess, you're a bower, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah ah
Why did you
say yes in addition
to that?
It's more important for the three of us to build a good relationship than things,
so
don't give up, don't you, so let's not
do that between us.
Ino:
That's right, doing that kind of thing only with Saki-chan is
because it's dishonest to Minase-
san.  By promoting interest, etc. hey
okay I
ended up thanking you can just in case
yeah yeah yeah ah ah ah ah ah ah
ah  Kana
w I'm happy
tan
yeah yeah yeah tan ran ni nan ana wh anglo adee
ana
[music]
me
good
tee
[applause]
[music] It
feels like 200 If my boyfriend asks me to
break up with him a break up b God forgives me  It's the first
time I've kicked it c
e